each year microsoft research helps
hundreds of influential speakers from
around the world including leading
scientists renowned experts in
technology book authors and leading
academics and makes videos of these
lectures freely available
good morning my name is Tandy Trower I'm
the general manager of the Microsoft
robotics group and it's my pleasure this
morning to introduce you to rod grouping
rod is from the University of
Massachusetts at Amherst you'll see I
won't read through what you already
received as rods extensive background I
think it's probably best to kind of
summarize it as saying that he probably
has one of the best jobs around there is
in terms of what he gets to do in terms
of putting all his working knowledge in
terms of physics and mechanical
engineering and computer science
together to build robots he's visiting
with us for a few days he and his his
team is visiting with us a few days here
at Microsoft we're doing some
integration work on between what he's
doing and Microsoft robotics to do but
this morning he's going to tell you a
little more about what his project is
and what his group does at the
University of Massachusetts and I think
it will be very exciting who going to
give you a preview or a show off his
robot to us as well so without any
further ado like to introduce rod rod
thank you for joining us today thank you
the real reason we're here in redmond
today is because of this robot and some
work that we're going to do locally with
the robotics to do people I'm going to
give a talk related to why we build such
robots and at the end I'll talk a little
bit more about what we're doing with
this one I've entitled to talk
developmental programming and
distributed robot control I put an
asterisk up there because when you see
distributed control you might think of
sensor networks and large-scale
deployments and things like that what
I'm going to propose is that distributed
control is really more ubiquitous than
that it's something that all control
devices processes that are in
manufacturing processes that describe
the computational architectures of
biological motor control neuroscience
and neurology our best represented in
terms of distributed computational
models so I'm going to talk about that
and mostly in the context of a walking
that form of by manual dexterity
platform we called extra back there 11
this guy no sensor nets made it into my
talk because I was getting too long
although we run those to it at umass but
the asterisk is to make sure that you
understand when I talk about this robot
I'm talking about distributed processing
and the interaction of many processes
that reside simultaneously concurrently
on the machine as well as many processes
that are external to it and happening in
the environment so here's an outline for
the talk I'd like the first overview why
we came to this model the sensorimotor
development in human infants is really
very remarkable if you haven't seen it
before it makes a very strong case for
why the control processes the way you
configure them the way that they come
online in the way that they disassociate
later is very much responsible for how
our brains mature cognitively into
adulthood and robots that are for
instance in elder care applications or
exploring Mars or something like that
cannot be programmed in the ways that we
have traditionally programmed software
they must react to new challenges as
they see them and build new models and
alter their software they might even
want to ship some of their software over
to adjacent robots to help them solve
problems in order to do that I'm going
to talk about the control basis
architecture in which we have a
substrate that is an embedded control
mode access methods to those controllers
that consist of you know protocols for
managing sensors and effectors we have a
middleware layer which and we've used
all of these I'll talk a little bit more
about this before we started with
backplane dma we went we tried scram net
which is just a reflektor an optical
reflector from back playing the
backplane we still use that a little bit
we try geni we tried player gazebo and
dds nasa uses so we tried that too and
none of them are very satisfying as a
middleware alternative we're here now in
redmond to figure out how to do the
microsoft robotics studio and apply that
as a middleware layer in all of the
applications we're building and then the
task level the application layer is that
is represented by this control basis
idea and I'll talk a little bit about
that but
the heart of the talk will be this
developmental assembler the idea that
you can actually guide a enter a robot
that interacts directly with the
environment through a sequence of
developmental problems that can acquire
knowledge structures that it reuses
again to write new programs and that you
are essentially embellishing temporarily
extended instruction sets for robots
which grow over time and do more and
more comprehensive behavior the examples
I've already talked about learning to
walk manual dexterity and then this guy
in mobile manipulators is where I'll end
I want to try to make the case for why
the future of Robotics is really in
robots like this small commodity robots
inexpensive that do lots of work and can
move and manually interact with the
environment delissa tomorrow thanks bye
this is an infant relax i'll let the
narration speak for itself stimulus and
there's a good moreau quiet headlight
midline and then just get a stimulus or
dropping him back a few inches and
that's a good normal response okay
newborn going to look for a row at this
age he may that was newborn there's less
immodest but okay these losses were out
at this point in time it's usually this
time they do is the room so doesn't have
a burrow so that's good all right so
this is a neurologist speaking and they
look at the onset of these reflexes
these are built into the spinal
circuitry and the and the cortical
projections in the brain from birth they
develop in utero and then they act to
bias the sensory motor system in a
particular direction so for infants they
emerge eight to nine weeks in utero and
they're inhibited by 16 weeks this is a
clasping reflex this is a reflex that
allows the infant to if you go back into
our ancestry to basically in response to
a vestibular instability to open up its
arms and grab the hairy back of its
mother in the trees right and make sure
it doesn't fall to the bottom stays in
the in the in the canopy and it's very
much responsible for helping the infant
survive
in order to learn anything in the first
place first step right so these are very
primitive after 16 weeks that transfers
transforms into a more adult-like
startle reflex if you hear a big bang in
the room everybody will kind of go like
that that's the descendant the the
antecedent of the Moro reflex having
been integrated into a lot of other
behavior I'm making the case about
children because this is the only way
that I claim intelligence sensory and
motor systems actually do mature into
adult autonomous independent agents that
can make independent decisions and deal
with environments they haven't ever
considered before this is another
example this is one that I'm
particularly interested in has to do
with palm or grasping you're all if you
have children you're familiar with this
we can elicit a grass reflex but again
putting the end right there and the
thumb and again the baby is able to
grasp we can open the hand by stroking
the side of the hand and then just
simulating a grasp reflex just by again
putting the hand right there and have a
go grass reflex okay
I'll vol see miscs you can actually pick
children up when ice reflects having
stimulated the proper gratitude is very
young age and then lift the baby if we
can get it quiet there you can see he's
almost pulling himself up as favors the
grass reflects need you to hold on that
hand as far as just putting pressure
here the bowls of also related to that
election legacy we have from the
canopies reflex that applies to the feet
and should and if you stimulate the ball
of the foot you'll get the toes to curl
over and try to grab that thing as well
you can see that there's a grasp reflex
as far as the grass reflux still has so
if they have abnormal persistence so
these are let's call them
preconditioning filters on the input and
output stimulus and stimulus response of
the infant and if you use them as
filters you bias the the developing
cortical projections to look for
relationships and associations between
certain signals and others and ignores
the vast majority of the information
that's coming from the world and this
allows the infant to be to program its
sensory motor responses in innocence if
they have abnormal persistence they can
delay manual dexterity hand to mouth
coordination swallowing problems and
remarkably they delay speech so there's
this might be anecdotal at this point
there's not too much evidence to support
strong conclusions in this regard but
your ability to start interacting and
forming categories in the world what
environmental affordances afford
grasping behavior for instance that
leads to the production of nouns about
the objects that you're grasping and
adjectives to describe their differences
between different objects and so starts
to lead to a kind of linguistic category
that describes those interactions with
the world
this is the Babinski and I'll truncate
this discussion a little bit the bin ski
is one that persists the neural
substrate remains cortical projections
inhibit it so this infant you will see
if he strikes that side strokes the side
of the foot will do a splay the toes
this way right now if you fall off your
motorcycle your bicycle or something
like that and bang your head the
neurologist will do the same thing and
if they get if they stroke your foot
like this and your toes play like that
that's big trouble that means that some
inhibitory cortical projections have
unmasked this developmental reflex again
so that whatever tissue had been lesion
din the in the trauma ceases to behave
as it should in a mature adult and
reveals the kind of underpinnings of of
this developmental system I'll this one
I'll skip by two just to mention if you
turn an infant's head he's laying on his
back supine on on the table there if you
turn its head to the side it will extend
arm and leg on the side you turn the
head to if you turn it to the other side
it will flex these and extend the others
has a lot to do as you can see with
maybe getting down the birth canal
unobstructed Airways if you this is crib
death kind of ideas this is a reflex to
try to minimize that it also extends the
focal apparatus to point at the hand and
they believe it's one of the big kind of
initiators catalysts of hand-eye
coordination so if there's a reflex it
constantly puts your hand in front of
the visual system then your ability to
get a good proprioceptive sense of where
your hand is relative your eyes starts
to be programmed also something a robot
should be able to do now let me just a
small tangent roboticists already know
how to write the equations to do all
this stuff why should we do this and
what I'm going to propose to you as this
talk builds into more complicated
applications is that if a robot has good
common sense knowledge structures about
how its own behavior affects the stimuli
it receives from the world it will be
able to react in intelligent ways in new
situations it has never encountered or
that the programmer has not
the equation for and that's the whole
point this one is the positive
supporting reflex let's see if i can get
this one to play because everybody
smiles and they say this trial death
it's good to this way and then sit up if
you put stimuli on the bottom of the
feet of the infant they will extend the
legs and try to prop themselves up in a
kind of a pillar like stance and this is
very much the thing that's striking
about this example is that they like it
it's fun when they exercise these kind
of pre-programmed tendencies in their in
their neurological organization it's
releases dopamine in their brains and
they smile they like it so their body is
not only given these initial kinds of
responses to the world they're also pre
programmed to really like it and want to
do it a lot this is a they're all
playing simultaneously there's a hiss do
people do kind of exact often eaten this
one is the most robot like and we push
the head reflex you can see it an infant
and if you hold them on the stomach they
go like Superman or as you push their
head down their legs flex top five
months of age he has now I don't know
really what this is for developmentally
but you can see that this is a machine
this is a robot if you will I don't mean
to demean infants in any way but we are
a machine and we have a very
sophisticated neurological sensory and
motor organization can we build that
kind of organization into robots and
then provide analogs of the processes
that turns that infant into an adult if
we can do that then we have a machine
that participates in its own programming
is parented in the programmer becomes
more like a parent than somebody who
sits at the keyboard and we end up with
robots that mature and can transfer that
knowledge on to the other robots all
right with that I just wanted to
emphasize that by watching a compiled of
chronology here's birth at about ten
months this is from point of conception
this is in utero and then after birth
and you can see that these reflexes like
moreau some of the ones we've talked
about they start and they end and the
normal development of a cognitive
organization starts and ends according
to a very reliable pattern if you just
if you depart from this pattern
you have developmental delays and need
an intervention essentially in order to
compensate for what you missed in your
experience and what isn't pictured here
is that some of these actually they
start to persist out to here but they
die and they go away they've served
their purposes and they atrophy and and
you can't elicit those responses anymore
and then certain others develop out into
adulthood so you get this sense that
there is a sent a non-stationary
programming environment one in which the
instruction set changes it's it's there
to make certain important cognitive
concepts conspicuous early in your life
and having acquired that knowledge in
your environment right so we can be on
the polar ice caps we can be in the
rainforest quite different environments
that we have to be able to adapt to we
only have a blueprint for it for
responding to those environments we
imprint on those environments on the
people around us on the society that
we're part of and then we build new
programs that reflect all of that
organization this is in fact a trace
that goes from a prone position to a
bipedal toddler stance and Patrick
Deegan who's in the audience and I'll
talk about a little bit later is doing
this on this robot which also has a
dynamically stable the potential to be
dynamically stable like a by peed but
the programming experience for this
robot can follow very much the same kind
of a structured discrete programming
sequence like this all right so what's
next in children while they start to
worry about after they master how their
bodies work in their relationships to
primitive stimuli in the world causality
they form categories when they start to
do when they start that postural
stability track to the point where their
hands are free an explosion of manual
dexterity activities start to happen
when that explosion of manual dexterity
starts to happen an explosion of
linguistic activity starts to happen so
you can see one kind of bootstraps the
next when their hands are free and they
can balance on their feet they start
exploring with their hands when their
hands are exploring they start labeling
linguistically the things that they're
interacting with I feel
strongly that hands are the key to
figuring out how our brains work what
makes us distinctively human and that
language is just an artifact or a part
of that process we get to anima see
intentions spatial representation
representations time and numbers the
things that are in red here I'm going to
speak to in the context of our
architecture and the kind of platforms
were using in subsequent slides so
here's that analog I was talking about
first of all we have a substrate the
next slide I'll talk about what that
substrate really means as an analog to
human beings but its sensors motors
distributed control and methods for
accessing the status of those
distributed controllers then we have
this middle where I was talking about
before and in the robotics to do is our
current middleware part of the
architecture a task level control basis
which I'll describe and then
developmental programming and that's how
I'm going to proceed now the rest of the
talk is going to be related to the
computational architecture not the
biological inspiration all right so
here's what this motor unit is this is
this was recognized way back by that car
Descartes if you put your hand in a fire
you will respond by withdrawing it that
will happen before your brain gets the
signal neural processes propagate
electrical voltages at a measurable
speed and is relatively slow between ten
and maybe a hundred meters per second so
when you stick your hand in that fire
pain receptors that are on the tips of
your fingers actually go back a spinal
nerve through one segment of the spinal
cord and then innervate flexion and the
muscles and get your hand out of the
fire there's firmware in your body it
keeps you alive keeps you from damaging
the fingers you're going to need later
to start constructing all those nouns is
the idea those are called motor units
alpha gamma motor units are typically
what happens and they form a
particularly important part of our
architecture so I'm going to this is the
computational model let me start over
here these are the motor units if your
control theorists this looks like a
simple closed loop transfer function and
you can represent it as such in this
robot it's implemented in 12-channel
FPGAs that do closed loop position
control
at two thousand Hertz something like
that dedicated machines that talk about
how motors muscles innervate kinematic
devices the control basis resides right
here it is a cartesian product of three
different parts of a closed-loop control
the artificial potential function right
so gradient descent on this potential
function is control our control inputs
for the motor units is the idea and the
potential function is constructed with
respect to a particular stimulus pattern
and affects a certain pattern of motor
or effectors so if you plug these
together you find an artificial
potential the means of assessing your
status on the artificial potential in a
means of descending that potential and
that becomes a closed loop this is
closed loop down here too right this
becomes a slower bandwidth hierarchical
closed loop control in terms of this
thing fee the artificial potential which
is like the intention of the system i
intend to optimize with respect to a
particular objective function alright so
now what happens is we watch those
controllers it this is a very big space
of possible controllers that you can
struck in fact we start with a
developmental stage which firsts limits
the range of fig fees and sigmaz and
towels that you're allowed to explore so
this is like the child with blurry
vision or low frequency hearing as they
emerged from the womb right that's not
just because your body didn't have
enough time to mature and it would
obviously be better if you had high
acuity vision it's throwing away
extraneous information that would only
confuse you it would only delay your
development it's focusing you on a few
features and saying what do you find it
so see ative relationships between these
kinds of signals you build a little
program and they keep that program says
I understand the relationship between
those that subset of my state space and
with that knowledge i can now stri to
attack the more complex real world so
that's the developmental stage and we
build those that's the programming
interface now to these guys the rest of
the structure is all built and native
processes in the robot
these build these control basis
closed-loop responses the potential
function and the rate of change in the
potential function is an activity
modeling enters this activity modeling
block and what we're doing there is
things like hidden Markov models and
abstract hidden Markov models and you
know such as the case when you're doing
speech recognition and things like that
or any of the other activity modeling
activity which is a popular in the
literature right now and you
characterize what's going on in the
world by virtue of how signals are
changing in response to controls that
you've constructed right so I like to
talk about the rabbit and the wolf the
wolf is trying to catch a rabbit and
he's watching his head pan and tilt as
he's trying to track visually where the
robot zigging and zagging right if you
can get the potential function to go to
zero it means you've closed the gap
between the wolf and the rabbit if it
doesn't go down to a place near the
origin of that plot it means the rabbit
is successfully eluding you this is all
very important information to try to
figure out what you should do next ok so
we model activities as the robot
interacts with the world and those
activities become a situation which
we're going to use as a surrogate for
state information in graphical models
like Markov decision processes where we
can do reinforcement learning and all
kinds of fancy adaptive optimal stuff so
we build a very structured space we hook
up Cartesian products of that space to
try to do experiments closed-loop
experiments in the world we model those
experiments we use the status of those
experiments to have to apply these
situations and then we use reinforcement
learning to attach a value function to
it one of the important hierarchical
abstractions is possible with an
approach like this is this very striking
relationship between these little
artificial potentials down here which
are like intentions like objectives and
value functions they are both have the
property that greedy descent on these
functions yield optimal behavior all
right so
once I build those I can stick this
construction this is a transition policy
in a discrete event system right I can
stick it down here I can associate
sensors and effectors with it and I can
do more experiments is there an object
in this room that I know that will
provide the affordance of grasp ability
right as soon as I know how to grasp I
can start that experiment and find out
that that cup is that plate is this
table is probably not given my finite
resources right so I start to be
inducing categories on them with respect
to hierarchical behavior so the way that
this goes about learning is we set up a
developmental stage it does let me flip
through the slides here and let you just
watch the progression I set up a
developmental stage I then stochastic
Lee sample I explore I put the Cartesian
product together and I start interacting
with the world through it it forms
combinations of things we can call
controllers in the control basis that
interacts with these lower level motor
units that are part of the robot we
model its activity we build the
structured Markov decision processes we
generate a value function on those
markov decision processes and then we
have this thing called a schema which is
in psychology and in AI and it is a
patterns plan or template for a general
class of actions that you're going to do
with the world the schema as a data
structure with formal properties is
loaded back into the control basis and
now we have temporarily extended
instructions that we can also explore by
stochastic sampling and we keep going
now there's a lot of work in our lab
about intrinsic motivation how do you
get this system to just kind of you know
disavow the trivial solution which is to
sit quiet not explore anything there's
no penalties involved with that you
don't use any energy right but there are
intrinsic motivations in humans and thus
in our robots as well for not being
quiescent but to actively try to find
models and explanations for them and
controlled transitions that it can rely
on that it can generate of its own free
will all right now if you want to use
one of the schema you just replace
you just use its value function then you
just do the arm acts if that's the
situation in and that's the actions and
the value function is a function of
those two parameters then you just pick
the actions that maximize the value and
so you just act in a greedy way and you
can act just like a controller again but
it's an underlying hierarchical discrete
space all right so here's an example
this was thing the first example we did
it's a little servo motor four-legged 12
degree of freedom quadruped it we have a
resource model that allows us only to
allocate in terms of effectors tell four
legs not the individual joints in the
leg and as a result of design I'm going
to talk about in a few seconds it led to
two to the 13 states in 1885 actions
possible from each state just as a
margin note here if I have we allow
concurrency even at the continuous-time
level if you have an artificial
potential in the form of a bowl
structure and your policy is to descend
it greedily then you want to go down the
gradient of the bowl that also means
that there's a ISIL level curve around
the bowl that says you didn't make any
progress towards the bottom right it's
orthogonal to the greedy descent and so
if you're going to go greedy on this
bowl another bowl can tell you another
action to go in and you project that
onto the ISIL level curve it means it
doesn't it doesn't destructively
interfere with the first priority
controller at all right this is formally
expressed in terms of more penrose
pseudoinverse a--'s was developed by
yoshikawa as a roboticist in the 1980s
and what we've done is really embraced
that idea and said if you express
everything as value functions or
potentials then you can combine every
form of behavior in these strictly non
destructive hierarchical organizations
very powerful and and I don't want to
leave that out but I'm not going to talk
too much about it in the rest of the
talk so we have four legs we have XY and
theta coordinate configuration of the
body we have four legs XY + theta
configuration as possible abstract
defectors that we can change the values
of
and we have something that's going to do
moment control if you're familiar with
bipedal look human oide most of them use
this thing called zero moment point
controllers where they just try to build
a quasi-static polygon in the supporting
structures of the feet and if the center
of mass of the robot falls into the
interior of that polygon then the robot
will stand there of its own accord right
not dynamically stable but it won't fall
over and if you lean forward in the
center of mass goes out of that polygon
then you're unstable and you got to
watch out so we have a moment controller
that just takes all the moments
generated by contacts between the feet
and the floor and wants to sum them to
zero and it's a form of zero moment
point control and we're doing it for
this robot the difference is we allow
the system to explore combinatory the
different combinations of legs that can
build those kinds of polygons and
kinematic conditioning a device a
kinematic device as you all know can do
forces and velocities and isotropically
if I if I if I my leg is a good example
of a singular configuration of a
kinematic device that is designed to
support my torsos mass above the floor
but it can't really generate velocities
radially from my body anymore in that
direction it doesn't very well in this
direction so I can run and I can hold my
weight up very sophisticated and elegant
design so because kinematic devices are
not a spatially isotropic in terms of
their velocity and force capacity we
need to figure out how to apply velocity
in force capacities of particular
configuration to a task and that's what
that does a lot of this is in papers
that you can get more details out of I'm
going to be somewhat superficial in this
talk all right so we construct the set
of controllers that's the moment control
this is kinematic conditioning mama
control is allowed to be configured by
taking us the input sensor stimuli any
triple of legs any tripod because a
tripod is the minimum stable
configuration right and it can descend
in order to try to stabilize the
platform by taking one of those legs and
moving it to a new location when it's on
when it hasn't converged it asserts a
predicate value of zero when it has
converged it asserts of predicate value
of
one says that tripod is now a possibly
stable tripod right the kinematic
conditioning takes all four legs and it
moves the heading of the body so as to
move all four legs simultaneously back
towards the middle of the space where
their isotropically condition forces and
velocity is equally well in all
directions that's that's it those are
the only two instructions I'm going to
allow this robot to explore in this
developmental stage as a result we get
eighteen hundred and eighty five
possible control combinations by
allowing one two and three of those to
be chosen concurrently from the set of
13 right because if you if you allow all
of these permutations you get 12 out of
that one out of that that's thirteen
controllers nest them one two and three
deep add them all up you get this many
the discrete events are is the 01 to
tripod stable is the 0 to 3 tripod
stable and so on so all I'm doing here
is saying you must assert predicates
summarize the dynamic status of this
robot by determining what combinations
of legs can currently lead it into a
stable configuration there's no task yet
right I haven't said anything about task
this is just a very structured minimized
very succinct tiny little corner of the
state action space and five predicates
30 that is 32 combinations of things
that the robot needs to be aware of
I can put logical constraints on this so
i can overlay my own neurological
organization by looking at the predicate
the same thing that says pull your hand
out of the fire before your brain knows
and say you may not try that or I'll
fall over and it can do it before the
level that's trying to learn anything
has to be aware of it so the first one
is at least one of the stable tripods
must be true at all times right don't
fall over single trial single trial
learning no reset you don't go pick this
robot up and put it back on his feet
it's got to learn in a single trial this
one is a little bit more abstract and
that's designer influence it says I have
to mime this one it says if my center of
mass is currently in the interior of
this tripod this polygon formed by this
tripod it can't simultaneously be in the
interior of this polygon this polygon
well that polygon and yeah leave my hand
there move my foot bat polygon right so
there's a line from lat foot to this
foot and the center of mass is on one
side or the other can't be on both
that's what that says that limits the
number of states and actions that are
actually legal in the system that
reduces it to 32 states in an average of
157 actions per state which is reduced
by ninety nine point nine four percent
from the initial expressive power of the
control basis so what we've done is by
applying just simple little resource
model and two little logical axioms
reduced identified just a tiny little
corner of the state action space
permitted by the control basis and in
that little corner we're going to try to
do stochastic exploration to find out if
we can write new programs that are
meaningful to the robot and this is
trivial this is an old experiment this
will go by rather quickly that is thing
from the top and what you're going to
see initially is the first maybe 15
seconds of the stochastic part of the
exploration within the legal corner of
the state action space right will fall
down and then it will flip you'll see
this number change to about 11 minutes
and then it will show you what the
greedy policy
is that it learned
hey there it is stochastic ly exploring
and that's a rotate gate and so what
we've done is we've conspired without
the knowledge of the robot to build a
state space in which it was like falling
off a log to find a gate that I think
the robot will find useful in the future
this is not part of its genetic
inheritance this is something I as a
programmer told it it should explore
that space you'll find something useful
it puts it away as a temporarily
extended action by using that
relationship between artificial
potentials and value functions that's
the program by the way these are the
actions these triangles denote null
space projection so this is a primary
controller that's a secondary controller
that's a tertiary controller this one
must project its inputs into the null
space of this one this one must project
its inputs into the null space of this
one so the primary controllers are
guaranteed to be protected from
destructive inputs from the subordinate
controllers these are the actions that
go around this central four-step gate
ninety-five percent probability if
you're in this state and you under that
action that you'll go to this one and so
forth the green denotes transition
probabilities in excess of ninety five
percent the blue ones are lower
probabilities and less frequently
visited states and so if you were to
bump into a curb it would take you off
over here someplace and the greedy
policy gets you back into the main cycle
so it's a program with contingency plans
built around what it explored and it's
now a macro we're going to call this a
controller put it in the control basis
and say if you would like to configure
that controller and use it instead of
the primitives go ahead all right so now
that program is this kind of a
transition model and we've done
something to factor it there's a
declarative part and a procedural part
and what we've done is we've factored
the two apart the declarative part is
the fees the objective function
procedural part of the sensor and
effectors you had to use so we said well
there's one instance we know that this
sequence of objectives yield some useful
work and then we have this procedural
part we say that's useful in this
context and maybe it will be the same
plan the same schema will be useful in
another
context if we use different resources
now that's an abstract ideal i'll show
you what i mean by it in a second and
you end up with a schema now from a
single sensorimotor program you
hypothesize the existence of a schema
general plan a general outline and it
has the procedural and declarative split
up what does that mean that means when I
give that program to this robot who also
has four independent limbs and can
interact with an object it executed that
behavior that's a rotate clockwise
rotate counterclockwise and it's only
doing the walking gait that the first
robot programmed in its context and what
we see is there's another assignment of
resources to that the procedural details
of that declarative schema can be
swapped out I can give it a different
four-legged robot it should do the same
thing I can give it a four legged hand a
four fingered hand excuse me for limbed
and it will do a rotate gate to you can
search now once you have a schema the
declarative part you can search for
different parameterizations of the
procedural details you can decorate the
schema differently and see whether the
transition probabilities are satisfied
and if they are you have another
instance of the same general plan with a
different robot to different effect now
we learned rotate it took 32 states 157
actions the we did it many many times
the result was the same was very stable
learning problem because it was so small
and well-structured in 11 minutes we
then start a step one which is like the
bipedal gait reflex we added the
primitives we added some more primitives
which made the state space bigger we
added more primitives in the rotate
macro that made it even bigger now if
you had no marginal impact of the
control knowledge you acquired in the
original macro everything should slow
down because you're just a bigger space
but what we found was that with the
policy this one the most complicated
design that we had that had the rotate
macro built into it within two hours it
was doing better than the primitives
without the macro alone within eight
hours it was doing about twice as good
and so what we found
if you bootstrap the system by putting
little chunks of knowledge in in the
right order that subsequent problems
become easier and easier go a third
level now we know how to rotate and we
know how to translate with a step macro
and we say solve this maze now if you
have tried to solve this maze initially
this is a simple maze but what you're
supposed to do is it's supposed to get
from this location here over to this
little red X on the floor doesn't know
about these obstacles in the way it has
to find a path we said don't use any
primitives just for the sake of argument
try just rotate and just translate
rotate and step those two macros we put
together it's got four states and four
actions and what you see here is the
real learning responses is it you wrote
the program in the context of the single
trial it notices things it puts them in
we have one more controller i forgot to
mention there's a harmonic function
controller which is a path planner and
so it tries to go straight to the X
notices an obstacle then it tries to
circumvent the obstacle and it does that
recursively and all the step and rotate
have to do is figure out when you should
be stepping wants you to be rotating go
play that again it's got four states to
macro actions I think I'll play it again
yes yeah there's a there's a
forward-looking I our bumper and when it
sees an obstacle in front of it it Maps
it into a configuration space and then
the new path goes around it and then it
figures out it's always trying to follow
the path that exists with rotate and
translate so there's there is additional
sensing there's one additional path
planning controller and then the macros
that existed already are trying to
figure out how to get to those places
yeah it was told it was told you want to
be over there at X Y and you're here at
X Y it met it the question is how does
it know where it's supposed to go and
how it's getting there it knew ahead of
time where the goal was and it's
counting its own leg strides so it puts
this grant its leg on the ground here
and kinematically it says I just moved
three centimeters and it does it again
yea which was amazingly accurate given
we didn't expect it to be that good all
right now my robot should run okay now
I'm going to leap into a new domain this
is grasping and manipulation this is our
platform Dexter that you see there right
now what it's doing is running a schema
that we call grasping schema and the
grasping schema applies little contact
sensors at the fingertips of those hands
to the object to try to figure out where
all the forces are in the in the by
manual grasp and there's a particularly
compelling signature of a stable grass
it's looking for that is doing a
gradient descent on the controller we
designed to do that right there it'll
grasp it when it's finally happy with it
now and what it is it's going to run a
second controller in the con in the null
space of the first one which is two in
kinematically condition the arms into a
place where they're more comfortable in
the middle of their workspace more
isotropic once it gets there it's going
to do a twist test says move it way over
to your left subject to the grass don't
drop the grasp right don't destructively
interfere with the grass you got to
preserve it the next thing is do another
grasp in the null space of this grasp
there's another condition that it can
formulate it reaper ammeter eyeses the
grasp schema and runs that gradient in
the null space of the original one and
then it can discard the first one right
so what I showed here is essentially
this transition then there's 11 bits in
this representation still relatively
small as a control representation and
all of these transitions are different
places it can go that don't violate the
condition that at least one stable grasp
is present at all times it learns the
topology of this graph it learns every
one of these arcs has a parameterised
controller
that makes that affects that arc and now
it can migrate around in this space so
if you say pick up that object don't
drop it do some manipulation to it to
assemble it into another object or hand
it to a astronaut that you're working
with or something like that but do not
drop it it has to find a path through
this structure this is a very structured
space and it can learn almost online
like our walking platform did
we allow the schema which is found here
to start to build different operational
contexts so in this case says well if
the objects too big I should grasp it
with two hands if it's too small I
should grasp it with one and it can do
that by stochastic exploration just say
well there's the object i'm supposed to
get it has certain sensory affordances
scale color texture that kind of stuff
and i can look for decision services in
that stimuli that would help me to
allocate the procedural details at this
point right so we learn how to
generalize what we already know have
learned in a particular developmental
context to other contexts I'll blow
through this pretty quick having done
that this is what the robot will do this
is simple roboticists already know how
to solve this we can write the equations
but if the robot knows it I claim it's
better than if it has an equation for it
and so we'd like the robot to know it
what is doing there is randomly
selecting actions within a set that we
permitted it to explore and it gets an
intrinsic reward for touching an object
for seeing an object and then a bigger
reward for touching the object it saw
and so it's randomly exploring actions
try and get the most reward out of the
system so you'll see the object always
stays within reach of its right arm and
it's doing the grasping thing and
there's no response and then it does the
vision thing and it sees that it figures
out if it puts it together in the
sequence it gets all of this tact all of
this feedback response from the
environment so it learns essentially to
touch what it sees and this is a native
reward structure we say is like dopamine
it's modeled after dopamine in the brain
however that's pretty primitive that's
the greedy one I think it'll show you
the greedy one in a second but it's a
simple pro when I present this to the
machine learning community what they say
is this is just trivial why bother us
with this this learning problem is too
easy and it is it's too easy it's not
pushing the state of the art in machine
learning it's pushing the state of the
art in programming and the next step is
to say okay that wasn't really a very
rich problem
just learned your arms are only of a
certain length whoops how'd that happen
well your arms are only of a certain
length learn when it's when they're too
when the objects are too far away for
you to grasp so it's using the greedy
policy it already knows as a possible
action the sequence of seeing something
triangulating on it reaching to that
location in closing its hand except now
we're giving it objects that are a
little too far out this is like what a
parent does when the child has already
mastered something you you screw with
their minds a little right you put it
just out of reach and say well now what
do you do it learns that it incurs a
penalty for doing an action which is not
rewarding so it learns that it shouldn't
reach the things that are out of reach
and so and so I won't let all that play
out these are longitudinal learning
experiments that we do without ever
stopping so we do the first one it gets
a policy we do the second one this was
done by a student in the lab this Xiao
Wu over the course of a weekend and he
basically stayed up all night two nights
in a row and trained it for 30 times on
this and then for 30 times on this thing
God as far as he could brightening in
the our lab currently we're trying to
get through a contiguous year of
developmental programming well maybe a
month first and then a year because the
software keeps changing underneath us we
make new decisions we have to start over
one of the important things about this
is that we have to make the software
architecture stable so that the
knowledge we get is all referred back to
the same kind of architecture or else if
you change if you you pull out my
nervous system in the middle of a
longitudinal learning experiment put in
a new one I have to start over vygotsky
a famous developmental psychologist said
that children learn how to point by port
it's a gestural communicative act right
they point to objects that they can't
reach even though they know they can't
reach it because if it sees another
affordance in the environment like that
big blob that it sees moving into its
workspace doesn't have any very precise
visual acuity but it does see a big
moving blob if it sees a big moving blog
coming in the workspace sometimes it
pays off to reach the things you know
you can't touch because they will change
the dynamics and push it into your
environment
and so this is an experiment in which he
tried to do the got ski and pointing and
the robot does learn how to point if
there's a human present if there's not a
human present it saves the penalty and
doesn't bother all right so now here's
the bottom line after doing this for a
long time see if I can stop that the
robot has lots of knowledge it knows how
to pick things up and place them in new
locations it knows about the effect of
scale on resource allocation so this big
object is picking up with two hands the
same grasping schema instead of two
fingers it's two hands right that's it
this is picking things up on the table
putting them in that yellow bin is what
it's doing it also knows about
handedness things that are on the right
it uses its right arm for things that
are on the left it uses its left arm for
so it's inquiring it's making a query of
the table it finds another object which
will satisfy the see and touch
affordance that was also graspable with
one hand and it applies the right arm to
go get it and then it does the same
thing these are all just up re
instantiations of the same general plan
the same general schema with different
procedural details I'll let this play
out just to prove that he will go for
that and you will use the hand that he
likes to use so this robot can be told
things please sort all the read things
into that bucket all the blue things
into that bucket I don't care how you do
it how you teach it you just teach it
red left bucket blue right bucket do it
any way you want right and that'll be
the next thing i want to show no not
that
well not quite the next I'll go through
these quickly because I'm running out of
time these are how it represents objects
Rob Platt who's now working at NASA
Johnson in the Johnson Space Center in
Houston is doing this for Robonaut did
this experiment is part of his
dissertation and he said basically with
just a little bit of information in this
schema idea and procedural details that
we learn one at a time he can now put
all those grocery checkers out of
business and build a million-dollar
robot that will do it for you he learned
about handles by the same method except
that a hole is a foreground object that
has a background segment through it and
if you see that it's particularly
compelling and as a reaching goal
because the handle affords very stable
and reliable grasping and the robot
learns that relatively quickly
and he goes on does a whole bunch of
other examples but I'll go on now
transfer if you have an architecture
like this it allows you to generalize
that's the whole point it allows you to
transfer as well the mirror neurons
story coming out of rizal oddities lab
these two videos I'll show in a second
suggest that the status of a massively
distributed control architecture is used
in many tasks recognition
differentiation execution communication
and gesture and language and programming
alright so that's my definition of the
mirror neuron story it's somewhat
provocative that's not the last word
we'll hear more about it but that's how
I want to think about it now and then
let me show you what rizzolatti noticed
this is a monkey who's had a recorder
put on a particular cell in the
somatosensory know in the motor cortex
right and it's the cell that governs the
pincer grasp to region themselves but
they got one a recorder on a cell and
you'll hear it when it grasps the food
pellet you'll hear a Geiger counter
sound go off that's the output of the
audio from the recording
I'm not overly
right so they verified every time they
give a food pellet does a pincer grasp
you hear the recording they got the
right recording site inside the animal's
brain now this is the moment of
breakthrough and I believe this is very
very much very much very close to when
they first notices you can watch as
expression if you draw your own
conclusions something just remarkable
happened just then the animal isn't
moving its muscles at all it's watching
somebody else do a pinta grab the same
cell is going off what they're
suggesting and that's what's that's the
evidence that i'm using to justify this
hypothesis it's not just this a matter
sensory cortex there's a large number of
intracortical projections that take the
sensation the affordances of the food
pellet predict a pincer grasp would work
the visual affordances of visual cues in
terms of features and movements that it
notices during a pincer grasp and
associates them with the pincer the
action of doing them the pincer grasp
and subsequently the reward of the food
pellet all of those things are causing
that cell to its in its embedded in a
very rich in cross modal association
matrix and that's what they're recording
it just happens to be in the area of the
cortex that's just prior to the motor
circuit right so what this animal is
doing is saying I just saw you do that I
know how to do that maybe I'll try that
this is the basis i believe for all
kinds of biologically plausible models
of imitation which is another form of
programming right so if you have you
want to teach somebody how to do
something you show them first why does
that work because all of their own
proprietary associations associated with
that task and fill in the details that
you're providing with the ones that they
would be using if they were doing it
themselves and then they just replay
that circuit right so we tried an
experiment in which we had a telly
operator John sweetie did this work
program the robot they said here's a
schema for picking and placing if you
look over here this is a schematic
representation of that schema it has
lots of contingencies lots of
transitions but basically that's the
prior to the first localized with your
eyes and that's after the last time you
touch the object and you left it
someplace else on the table or something
right and there's many paths through
here that you could take you see the
telly opera is not very good at this but
what's up there is a sequential diagram
and basically you're using a hidden
Markov model to parse the transitions
through that diagram the robot notice is
all you went from here to there it's
confidence that you're actually trying
to demonstrate pick in place as a schema
goes up right it doesn't know why you're
doing it the way you're doing it it just
thinks you're trying to tell it they
pick in place is the goal so it puts the
orange thing over there and it's going
to do the same thing with the blue thing
and put it over there but it's not much
tedious to watch and so just take my
word for it in the process of doing that
it says all blue goes to is a pickup
reference sensory reference for picking
things up and the bin on the right is
the sensory reference for where I should
put it down if it's blue orange is the
sensory reference for pick up if it's
the left box I should be putting it down
in right and it so all it does is it has
this general background knowledge it
says these two things very simple one
trial will show it in general that's not
the case but we bias the system so the
colors were the things that it used to
discriminate all right now this is the
interesting thing we tell it okay sort
these objects in a manner that is
consistent with what we demonstrated and
now the robot can play back all of that
prior background knowledge it knows
notice the bins are not in the same
place notice the arm is not in this
weird configuration that facilitates
teleoperation the robots making its own
decisions saying I would like to reach
to it like this with my arm and this
geometry and by the way I just did it
with my left hand although you never
demonstrated that because I prefer to
pick things up on the left with my left
hand I'll put it in the bin that's on
the left even though it's
where you told me the goal was this is
the sensory affordance of the goal not
the not a spatial position itself and so
by teaching it using the schema
transition model as the template that
you can match to in a kind of a hidden
Markov model you can then say yes that
is the right template here are the
parameters that describe the
implementation of that template in a
particular case and I'll play it back
any old way I feel like the robots at
expressing its preferences in the matter
and gets higher throughput
higher-quality responses all right so
now I got to I've got to conclude here I
think I believe I have three or four
more minutes mobile manipulation this
gets us back to the reason why we're
visiting here in the first place and
this robot that I started to talk with
mobile manipulation promises to project
physical work into many of the places
that information can now currently go
that is if we allow computation and
networks to to act as a communication
medium between robots and humans and
robots and other robots now we can put
this in an elderly clients house and it
can take out the trash for them it allow
it as an embodied interface for human
beings medical providers for instance to
interact with the client on a daily
basis it can log lots of data that is
not being logged it can do emergency
response and I want to close with some
of the concepts that we've been trying
to develop at umass related to
residential health care with distributed
robots in the vet and you know of course
my pitch is there to rich and they have
too many options and you have to program
them developmentally you can't
anticipate everything they're going to
do ahead of time you have to embed them
let them in print on a client and
imprint on the clients environment and
become good at the things the client
needs this follows after the NSF NASA
report on autonomous mobile manipulation
that said that there's huge market they
projected billions of dollars in market
in as little as a decade related to
manufacturing logistics and supply
chain support agriculture and
construction space exploration and
residential health care these are the
two that i want to show some examples
will on and they also identified the
major challenges technically an
otherwise to making this happen one of
them was funding from federal force
sources and and and that's still a
problem but others were commodity mobile
manipulators it could be disseminated
widely so that people could learn how to
do this first and then put them in the
field to do the work the other was
programming methodologies for open
environments by open environments it
means environments that you can't
possibly anticipate and predict ahead of
time and then just write the terminus
tech programs for them or any kind of
programs for them so our effort here is
in this you bought this is a you bought
for this thing on the table is that you
bought five the next in the series this
is Patrick Deegan on the screen there
are the particulars I want to point out
a few things it has a webcam and has a
screen and it has a gaming interface on
the remote side so that you can see you
can do a skype conversation through the
network with a local client who treats
it just like a teleconferencing kiosk
that moves around in space but this one
can point this one can bring the voice
of the person to you if you're not near
the kiosk that you would normally use it
can also pick up things and interact in
various ways that regular kiosks
couldn't this is an example of another
graph that says you may not fall down
and basically it started in prone and
it's executing this transition and once
I guess that this one it's going to try
to get to balancing so these are
constructions that were the result from
this developmental programming paradigm
which are consistent with the other ones
I showed you for by manual manipulation
and other things this robot should
protect itself if it's trying to get
over someplace not a cup a bag or take
out the trash and you throw a book or a
rock in front of it at trips it should
take all the actions necessary to
protect itself those safety constraints
that I was talking about before restore
its condition and then continue with its
task and you shouldn't have to worry
about whether that contingency will come
up in a particular application or not it
should just be there background
knowledge and common sense is a lot
about
what we're talking about in a
developmental programming paradigm
here's a NASA asked us to take a look at
a few examples now they have want to
land things on the moon again and they
want to build habitat whether it's the
moon or the Mars or Mars we're not
really sure yet they keep changing their
mind but the idea is when they went in
the early Apollo missions they had
Landers land near other landing sites
and they noticed that there's no gravity
and there's no atmosphere nothing slows
down the blast from deceleration would
throw regolith lunar dirt out in all
directions and it was very abrasive and
it would essentially scour all the metal
off the facing side of the other landing
site so they want to land habitat
modules and these things here are what I
want to call habitat modules are really
hate buckets we need to acquire them and
move them we need to assemble them into
given configurations we need a
general-purpose manipulator that doesn't
have to presume terrain gravitational
field the presence of other robots the
geometry of the final assembly it needs
to be able to be told these things and
then be able to construct plausible and
relevant efficient motor programs for it
and so what you see here is that the
habitat module acquisition emplacement
idea and NASA Ames is building a robot
called athlete which is a big six legged
mobile manipulator to do some of these
things the other example is once you
assemble the habitat into the right way
you have to berm it with regolith that
will insulate it from lots of
temperature extremes actually there's
thinking about digging a whole building
inside the hole and then blowing up a
balloon and then covering the whole
balloon with regular regular mining and
moving is important to them too if you
mine just a few centimeters of regolith
which is very silicate rich and
oxygen-rich as a result over about the
area of a football field then you throw
it into some processes that remove the
oxygen from the compounds that are in
the regolith you can supply enough
oxygen for a crew for for six months in
just a few centimeters over a football
field so little robots even this
one that does it at this rate could be
entirely plausible as just autonomous
miners that deal with the terrain and
the crater structures and all that kind
of stuff and even optimized where they
get the regolith from by the output of
the chemical conversion processes you
don't need big mass production devices
for a crew of four for instance you just
need a couple of these maybe you also
have to berm the regolith up around the
habitat module so that when they land
new habitat modules over here it doesn't
scour all the front-facing metal off of
the old ones and so this robot this you
up for is acquired a little tool which
is like a bulldozer bucket and it's both
mining and firming a habitat and that's
what that one's about now these are not
the result of a developmental
programming paradigm these are concepts
demonstrated by virtue of a remote tele
operator here are some other concepts
related to health care this is a family
interface so you see Adam over here
doing a Skype interaction with Grandma
and his face is there and they are
talking and you can take it by the hand
and it's a force feedback robot and you
can lead it around you can show it the
new flowers in the garden or the new
pictures you got from you know that kind
of stuff so you can increase the kind of
social interaction between a elderly and
sedentary may be housebound client and
the rest of the family in the community
and you can also do it for medical
services here's I heard if if you see
somebody fall down and it's inexplicable
and they get up and they look okay shake
off their head and they sit down one of
the things you should do is you should
immediately do a home-style stroke
evaluation you should ask them just to
move their facial muscles by saying some
words say some words that stimulates the
linguistic centers of the brain who's
some gross motion and smile i think
that's facial muscles linguistic and
gross motion right if they pass their
okay if they don't take him to the
hospital immediately time is of the
essence right so we had an example of
this in my hometown where grandma fell
down they got up they went about
Thanksgiving anyway that night she died
apparently had a massive stroke not
necessarily apparent by virtue of just
you know because you compensate you
don't want to be embarrassed so you
don't move your arm
if it won't move and you don't tell
anybody about it right this doctor who's
our lab manager Emily her L gets into
the robot here and does the stroke
evaluation it has the Skype interface
you can observe what's happening you can
even demonstrate the motions you want
them to try that's the the difference
between an embodied interface and a
kiosk the last kind of concept is when
does that person fall down is
unresponsive what happens then and so
what we've done is we put a digital
stethoscope on the end of that the
doctor or the emergent emergency medical
technician applies the stethoscope
drives the robot the robot can do this
by itself there are fall detection
events they're out in the literature we
have 12 it can drive itself or it can be
driven you can apply the stethoscope get
a telemetry back to the EMT who's in the
ambulance on the way to the scene and
have the neighbors alerted in all that
kind of stuff if you put this kind of
device that can both be an information
interface and have the potential for
doing mechanical work remotely in
response to external remote users or
autonomously you have saved a great deal
of time and money in healthcare and
allow elder clients to stay in their
home a little bit longer the last
demonstration turns out eighty percent I
think I have these figures right eighty
percent of deaths due to household
accidents are because of falls in elder
clientele and they might trip over
something and then they'll break a hip
and then they'll have complications and
they end up dying so one of the things
that you can do to improve the quality
of life and safety of elder clients is
just to clean up get their laundry off
the floor get inadvertent boxes off the
floor here's a little mock-up of a one
that we did on the left you see our
sensor array has modeled activities in a
space it knows the corridors by virtue
of remember those fees and then changing
fees and those models like the activity
modeling part it knows that if you see a
person here they're going to head down
the hallway in one or two directions
they don't ever turn and go into the
wall right so it has activity corridors
and it's mapped them out for all the
moving human objects in the environment
and that's supposed to be a depiction of
it over there those are just places
where humans commonly frequent and then
we had the UPS man in the form of Shiraz
sin in our lab come in and deposit a box
in place the robot sees that that's in
an activity corridor and generates a
path plan like the legged walker that
find its way through a maze it heads out
over and pushes the box into a place
which is outside the activity corridor
and prevents perhaps a future fall and
these kinds of technologies are very
simple you won't want to build
independent technology for each
application you want one application
that will possibly do them all and
that's the important part and here is
the last slide second to last anyway
which is some work that we're doing with
cynthia brazil about the robot that you
see on the table is going to be
implemented in a much more sophisticated
way using hands that were built by jeff
weber at MIT and heads that were built
by the media lab in collaboration with
other people and digit robotics is
building the chassis like you see here
on the table and zaida me is integrating
all these pieces together and the first
one is actually being put together right
at this moment the head is not yet ready
but the hands are on I believe and this
is very exciting this would be a very
expensive robot but it'll be an
unprecedented I think entry into social
this is called mobile dexterous and
social robots as per the media labs
primary interest and finally
acknowledgments we've got to do this
work we've gotten a great deal of
support from DARPA and National Science
Foundation NASA's provided some support
AR 0 and 0 on our and I should cite
Microsoft has given us a little bit of
money in order to develop a an
application for this robot as well so
thank you very much all the people that
are contributing are over on this side
most of our lab Cynthia Brazil and two
previous graduates from the lab thank
you
guess we have some time for questions if
anybody has any
should not be where the robot
different configurations in your lap his
lap times or the left and then like
after the video kind of ended before we
got to see what she happened to do
before that I was really wondering what
happened because late because that
hunting things it up wasn't going to be
able to reach him ah oh I'm sorry I
stopped it there we did that on purpose
well it didn't have enough common sense
to really get to an integrated solution
at that stage in development so what it
did was it went like this and that
reaches far over to it as it could and
then dropped it there then what happened
is it started up another instance of the
same kind of program notice that the
right color ball was for that bin was
right there used his left hand to get it
and put it the rest of the way in and
then later on with more experience in
that particular task it knows that
there's additional value because it can
reach things across the center line it
doesn't have to be mutually exclusive it
knows there's additional value to
instead of just being a single handed
preference if it's a pic and placed
asked if there's a single hand that does
both the pic and the place that that's
less costly than if you do this transfer
move and it learns that with additional
stages of learning you just have to give
it training examples that point that out
yeah this is very nice reminds me I'm
not in this area
complex of genetic program that would
soon you use in a primitive as basis who
uses higher level abstractions that
procedure is like a function call as a
basis
to composing these strategies
and this in your contacts Marco
presentation of your abstract
yes there there there are a number of
related conceptually related ideas out
there Miami target USC has done it with
sub sumption architectures and behavior
basis and she calls a behavioral basis
as you noted genetic algorithm people
use genetic ga solutions to certain sub
problems and try to combine them into
new ones and through the mutation
operators and all that kind of stuff
that's also used to some advantage by
incorporating structure and incremental
training incremental programming and
structure and then reapplying it
hierarchically the main insight that we
have is not in the sense that you can
build that you can divide and conquer
that's been around for a long time our
insight has to do with the conceptual
similarity between something called an
artificial potential and something
called a value function and they're both
adaptively optimal so the once I build a
program of programs the resulting
representation of that schema is
precisely the same has all the important
properties to just call it a controller
and throw it back in the mix and by
doing so we can now take control actions
which are and also the other big
contribution is that that factor ability
issue if I pull the artificial potential
out and call that the intention it
describes a whole class of actions and
then I can dissociate it from the
procedural details and attach them later
so yeah there's a lot of good
foundational work that suggests that
this is the general way to go about
these problems we've just added a few
little added benefits of our own with
respect to our applications
okay can you decide for what what are
the right common sense building blocks
you do that based on the task that do
you think the role
break it down into the logical subtests
or are you the role the programmer is
not gone in this system it's doing
autonomous learning but basically it can
it can be as ineffective as any program
if it's randomly typed in at the
keyboard today right so if if you're a
malicious parent and you teach it
contradictory concepts it won't learn
anything so that is an open question the
the new in these sensory motor systems
the new role of the programmer is much
more like being a parent and it turns
out that biological systems are also
predisposed pre-programmed genetically
to be relatively good parents Mother's
speak to their children in mother ease
they raise the frequency they speak in
different cadences and different sounds
and they evoke a point a lot what
they're doing is they're pointing out
the kind of sensory and motor references
they're appealing to the auditory
channels that the child is most
sensitive to and they're basically being
good parents without even knowing it
perhaps but in fact is a nice resonance
between what the child's prepared to
accept and what the mother delivers and
so programmers also have to think about
how to be a a good and effective
programmer in this context and we don't
have as many answers there as we do
architectural answers at least beginning
with us falling to the parents adopting
here they like
yeah you're getting your own dopamine
kind of response when your child can
smile yeah yeah there's definitely there
is both the role of child and the role
of parents in the gene pool when we're
born and eventually if development goes
as as normal we'll be in a position to
anticipate how to deliver control
knowledge to another copy of a human
being at some point in the future so
being a teacher and being a student are
very related activities and and
unfortunately these robots are very
different than the human programmers
that I'll have to deal with them so we
have to kind of adopt a new strategy
figure out what works now the
interesting thing about it is that you
could resort just the stochastic you
could just give it a structured space
and say I don't know anything more about
this go at it explore it's possible that
that will yield some interesting robot
behaviors that are not human in
conceptual structure those those robots
can then act as teachers to the other
robots potentially one day we can't do
it yet but it would be nice we're now
trying to see all those bimanual
activities that you saw with Dexter of
course he has fingers and everything but
when he's doing big objects with two
hands this robot should be able to do
the same things so we're trying to see
now whether Dexter can actually either
just port the software in schematic
format into this robot and have him
search just in the procedural details
not in the schematic details or whether
perhaps there's a way for the robot to
actually conceive of a simple example
like the tele operator did in that other
case i'm going to show you this ball
goes here this ball goes here now do
whatever you want solve the rest of the
problem maybe Dexter can actually serve
as an instructor or programmer for this
robot as well it's not in the short term
all right there are no other questions
thank you very much and as everything
before this robot should be running
around in the hallways later this week
so keep an eye out and the people that
are responsible for most of the work are
in the audience if you need an
introduction let me know